yeah trying to get you safely out the
door here before 5 30. freeway is
generally in good shape with this huge
exception up there with the Northbound
I-15 is completely shut down at the Las
Vegas Motor Speedway you are able to get
through but the backup is growing now
back towards the 215 Northern Beltway
this happened before two o'clock this
morning here's a picture from the
Regional Transportation Commission
camera just looks like a jumble of
Lights we have a much better view from
our own photographer Armando on the
scene that is a jackknife tractor
trailer across all Lanes of the
Northbound I-15 so let's head on back to
the traffic computer so not only are you
dealing with that but on your way to
that seam if you're getting off the
north 15 at Tropical Parkway to go to
the industrial area the Amazon
warehouses and whatever guess what there
is yet another crash so the freeway
lanes themselves are open but you are
starting to back up towards the northern
215 Beltway that is causing a little bit
of a delay again they're diverting you
off at the speedway back onto the
freeway plan on delays rest the freeway
system pretty good John Heather